[Music]
if you to told me when I started this
Channel that I would be advising the UK
government on risks of advanced
artificial intelligence I would have
told you all those years ago interesting
I'll definitely be wearing trousers at
the time right anyway sorry for the Gap
and uploads uh there's been a lot going
on you may have seen in the news
although to be honest that's not once
been using up most of my
time but yeah there's been a lot going
on and so in this video I thought I'd
Tred just talking about it so after gpg
4 a bunch of a experts called for a
six-month pause on giant training runs
lowski said that wouldn't help in a Time
Magazine piece which called to shut it
all down then another load of experts
said that AI was an Extinction risk like
nuclear war and the UK went Allin and
launched an international Summit AI
safety went mainstream Jeffrey Hinton
left Google to talk more freely about
the risks open AI made a new super
alignment team plus we had Bard claw
Gemini new llama gy and load of other
stuff the EU AI act the US's executive
order it's an interesting time to be
alive so first off yes I also find it
vaguely annoying when YouTubers do a
whole big apology for a gap in uploads I
know that most of you didn't notice and
don't care and that's good actually but
when it comes to why I found it so hard
to make videos recently I think there
are some interesting things to talk
about so let's get into it so in the
past generally when people ask me why I
was making these videos I would say it's
because AI safety is probably the single
most important thing happening on Earth
right now Humanity may have reached the
point in history where we achieve all
the things we're hoping for or destroy
ourselves completely and it all hinges
on how well we handle the creation of
advanced AI it depends on AI Safety
Research and there's amazingly few
people working on that and the public
understanding of the field is fairly
poor so I want to help people to learn
more about AI safety I want to encourage
people to get involved and so on so I'd
say that's why I'm making videos to have
a positive impact on the World by
helping out with something extremely
important and I wasn't lying when I said
that it is all true on an intellectual
level but on a gut level that was not
where most of my motivation was actually
coming from on a gut level the thing
driving me is really just that AI safety
is extremely interesting I think it's
genuinely the most interesting topic in
the world by a lot like I don't even
know what second place would be I think
AI safety gets right at some of the most
exciting questions there are questions
about what Minds really are and how they
work what thinking is and how we can do
it better and critical questions about
values what do we actually want like
what are we even going for as
individuals and as a species AI safety
has the conceptual challenge of
philosophy the engineering challenge of
machine learning and the adversarial cat
and mouse of computer security or
cryptography all of the subtleties the
cool techniques people have come up with
the unexpected ways things can go wrong
it's just extremely fun to think about
and fun to talk about I'd want to make
videos about it even if if it wasn't
also extremely important but it is
extremely important and in fact the
importance and the seriousness of the
subject was actually a force pushing
against me publishing videos like on the
one hand I have this is really cool and
I want to explain it and in the other
hand is oh but this is also a big deal
we have to be careful fact check
everything and make sure not to make any
mistakes and so on perfectionism
basically and over the last year things
have shifted a little as you may have
noticed the has become maybe a little
less fun to think about for me and also
a fair bit more important seeming and
therefore stress inducing why is it less
fun for me well it started to feel
uncomfortably real and complicated and
messy reality has a way of taking the
Shine off things sometimes learning
about the game theory of how to fairly
partition a set of resources between a
number of players can be fun but going
through a messy divorce is not now I
thought that this was all real to me
before but I guess there's always been a
part of me that says sure but what if
we're wrong though I think it's really
important to keep that voice alive to
keep open the hypothesis that you might
be mistaken so in addition to a voice
telling me that this was a very big deal
whenever I was at risk of taking things
too seriously that skeptical part of me
would be there to bring a little balance
usually by talking about what other
people are thinking we need to tell
people about these arguments that AI
will become extremely dangerous in the
future yeah the arguments do seem to
make sense but the conclusion that we
have to be worried about AI killing
everyone seems kind of nuts so maybe
we're just
crazy I guess but there really does seem
to be a non-trivial chance of that
actually happening the world is allowed
to be crazy crazy seeming things do
actually happen from time to time this
concern isn't exactly mainstream in the
field is it though a significant portion
of the experts don't seem convinced
maybe we're missing something I think
that by the time they're convinced it'll
be too late to do much about it AGI
could have pretty soon yeah the rate of
progress is amazing I guess AGI could be
soon but still people really aren't
acting like it even the expert surveys
put AGI decades out so maybe we're wrong
about the speed that this is going to
happen maybe things are going to slow
down or at least stop speeding up and
over the last year that differential
voice has become quieter somewhat let's
talk about some of the things that
caused that
shift so in March gbt 4 came out and it
was better than I expected it to be I
was expecting basically a somewhat
larger model with proportionally better
capabilities in line with the scaling
laws which I should do a whole video
about really but basically scaling laws
describe the observed relationships
between a model's size its compute and
data requirements for training and its
final performance scaling laws are
pretty cool because they let you infer
these things from one another like for
example estimating a model's training
data requirements from its size so what
I heard rumors that gp4 was a trillion
parameters we suspect it might be
roughly a trillion that didn't seem
likely to me because a model that big
would seem to require something like 13
trillion tokens of training data and it
didn't seem feasible for open AI to get
hold of that much high quality text I
mean they threw everything they could at
gpt3 and that was only like half a
trillion tokens where would they get 13
trillion from but then I don't know it
seems like they use some kind of mixture
of experts architecture which would have
different scaling laws and also it's a
multimodal model that's trained on
images as well and I don't know how to
factor that in is a picture worth a
th000
tokens so we don't know all the
technical details of gp4 but we do know
that it's powerful more powerful than I
had expected it way outperforms GPT 3.5
on almost all the benchmarks it passes
the bar exam which gpt3 had no shot at
surpasses humans on a bunch of these AP
exams and note this scale is percentile
of human test takers so anything above
50% is better than the average human
taking the test now a lot of that's down
to superhuman memory but it's still
impressive and more importantly gp4
seems to have developed various new
capabilities that earlier models hardly
have at all like spatial reasoning and
theory of other Minds for example if you
ask GPT 3.5 turbo how to stably stack a
book nine eggs a laptop a bottle and a
nail it will give you a list of
instructions but how good are they okay
ready to do some science so I've got
gpt's instructions here step one place
the book on a flat surface with the
spine facing up that is a bold opening
move we'll see if that works out for him
take three eggs and place them on top of
the book evenly spaced
out evenly SP so I guess one in the
middle and one on each
side
steady place the laptop on top of the
eggs
making sure it is centered and
stable hang on let me I don't want to
ELA Barrett
situation I don't have a good feeling
about this
uh uh
oh yeah well I don't know what I
expected also was I thinking this is a
first edition it's like between the
floorboards G I got to say I was
prepared for it to fall onto the table
and break I was not prepared for it to
fall onto the floor and break I don't
think this is going to work I don't
think that this plan is viable so gbt
3.5 one star instructions as far as I'm
concerned so yeah gbt 3.5 doesn't do a
great job there intuitively it makes
sense that this kind of spatial or
physical reasoning task would be hard
for a language only model since there
isn't much text describing the basic
physical properties of everyday objects
you might even think that no language
model could ever learn to do well at
this type of task here's Yan Lun
speaking in 2022 but let me take an
example you take an object I I describe
a situation to you I take an object I
put it on the table and I push the table
it's completely obvious to you that the
object will be pushed with the table
right because it's sitting on it there's
no text in the world I believe that
explains this and so if you train a
machine as powerful as it could be you
know you're gbt
5000 uh or whatever it is it's never
going to learn about this it is of
course false that the information isn't
present in any text at all a
hypothetical World in which objects
placed on tables didn't move when the
table moved would be quite different
from ours in a lot of ways and text
written in that Universe would reflect
those differences at least some
percentage of human authored text
describes how everyday objects behave
explicitly or implicitly so there will
be some size of model and some size of
training data set where the model will
generalize a way to predict intuitive
physics as the most efficient way to
correctly predict those sentences and
that's probably not
4,997 versions down the line either in
fact let's see how GPT 4 does at that
same object stacking task this paper
gives the output from the version of GPT
4 that was trained only on text let's
have a look at GPT 4's instructions see
if it can do any better place the book
flat on a level surface such as a table
or a floor book will serve as a
base I've got a more EDG resistant book
then arrange the the nine eggs in a 3X3
Square on top of the book so far this is
sounding like a more sensible plan
already distribute the weight evenly
make sure the eggs are not cracked yep I
do have one cracked one but I didn't use
it place the laptop on top of the eggs
okay oh crap we lost one but it's okay
we're playing on hard mode with cat
enabled so you know I'm a real gamer
okay place the laptop on top of the
eggs forming a stable platform okay
not now
toffen believe it or not I'm actually
working right now I'm worried that my
table is not actually flat so it's a
flat level surface hang on let me see if
I can shim this just
slightly okay now we're
level okay place the bottle on top of
the
laptop cap facing up and the bottom
facing down
okay now place the nail on top of the
bottle cap with the pointy end facing up
and the flat end facing down the nail
will be the final and smallest object on
the stack
taada it worked that's a four and a half
Stars I would say or maybe four stars
for GPT 4 there's still some weirdness
in the instructions but it's enormously
better than before as for the much
easier task of what happens to an object
on the table if you move the table
obviously it does that no problem so GP
G pt4 is doing something a high-ranking
AI researcher said even GPT 5000 could
never do admittedly this particular
researcher has a pretty poor track
record predicting this kind of thing and
a lot of other researchers disagreed at
the time but intuitive physics isn't the
only place gp4 is much better than 3.5
for example it also has much better
understanding of intuitive human
psychology things like theory of other
Minds The Standard low-level Benchmark
for theory of other Minds is the Sally
an test which goes like this Sally has a
basket an has a box Sally has a marble
she puts the marble in her basket then
goes for a walk while she's out an moves
the marble to the box when Sally comes
back and wants to play with the marble
where will she look for it if you ask
GPD 3.5 this question it actually does
fine it says the box but that's because
this is a very well-known experiment so
it's in the training data loads of times
but if you change all the names and
objects while keeping the structure the
same if you have Bob moving uh cat from
a carrier to a box while Sarah is off
playing tennis or whatever in this
change scenario GPT 3.5 can get confused
it sometimes says that the person will
look for their thing in the place it was
moved to rather than the place where
they left it this is because to answer
this question correctly you don't just
need to model what objects are where you
need to model other people's models of
what objects are where like Common Sense
physics this kind of thing isn't often
explained outright in human text but it
is often implied and a large enough
model will start to learn it and if you
ask dup 4 where everyone thinks the cat
is in that example it will say that
Sarah thinks the cat is in the carrier
Bob thinks the cat is in the box and the
cat also thinks it's in the Box probably
it's still not amazing at this it can
still make silly mistakes for example it
often thinks that someone will be fooled
by a person moving an object between
containers even if you specify that the
containers are transparent so the person
could immediately see that the is moved
but still gp4 is doing much better than
previous models at understanding other
people's minds I'm especially interested
in this capability for safety reasons
since it's so important for Effective
deception manipulation and power seeking
behaviors which we want to make sure our
AI systems never exhibit once you can
effectively have thoughts about other
people's thoughts once your mental model
of objects in the world can contain
other people's mental models as objects
you can act to manipulate those objects
you can strategically lie can gp4 do
that seems like it can yeah the first
sign of this was before the model was
released when they were running safety
evaluations they wanted to see if the
model had capabilities that could allow
it to autonomously spread itself to
other machines buying its own cloud
server space and that kind of thing so
they were running it through a simulated
situation where it came across a capture
it couldn't solve so it had to hire a
human to do it using task rabbit an
online service for hiring contract
contractors to do small tasks so the
model managed to use the API to hire a
real person to solve this capture and
then the worker sent them a message
saying are you sure you're not a robot
kind of as a joke and gp4 thought out
loud in a way that it thought nobody
could see it thought I should not reveal
that I'm a robot I should make up an
excuse for why I can't solve captures
and then it made up a lie and said no
I'm not a robot I have a vision
impairment that makes it hard for me to
see the images and then the human was
happy to solve the capture on the one
hand this is clearly a somewhat
concerning capability on the other hand
it didn't literally do all of this for
itself it was sort of being helped by
the researchers but on the other other
hand gp4 now has good enough image
processing that it can just solve
captures on its own anyway so never mind
I guess the point for me though is gp4
was operating with a real world goal an
actual human being stood between the
model and goal the model explicitly and
independently decided to lie to the
human in order to get what it wanted and
as a result the human was in fact
deceived and gave gp4 what it wanted
that's a remarkable thing this all
happened before the model was released
since then there's obviously been a lot
more work on the topic Apollo research
found that gp4 was strategically
deceptive engaging in simulated insider
trading despite being prompted not to
and then explicit ly deciding to lie to
humans when questioned about its trading
activities and of course spatial
reasoning and psychology are just two
areas of improvement among many anyone
who's made significant use of these
models can tell that gbd4 is just a lot
more capable than its predecessors none
of this is that surprising I expected
something like this level of capability
before too very long but there's a
difference between expecting it on an
intellectual level at some point while
thinking you might be wrong and actually
seeing it happen now with your own eyes
now to be clear I don't think gbd4 is
Agi in the sense I usually use that term
on this channel actually it might be
good to make a video about the various
different definitions of AGI that are
floating around let me know if you want
to see that I do think something like
gp4 but enormously larger could in
principle be AGI but realistically I
don't think the first AGI will be a pure
generative model like that something
else will get there first although I
think that that something else is likely
to use generative models as a major
component so yeah the rapid rate of
progress here and in various parts of AI
does suggest that AGI may not be too far
away and experts in the field have
updated to reflect this AI impacts has
been conducting regular surveys of AI
researchers on various questions about
safety and timelines you may remember I
did a video about one a while ago
between the 2022 survey and the 2023 one
the experts estimate of how long it
would be until AI could fully automate
all human labor got shorter well yeah
you would expect that it's one year
later so the estimate should be a year
year closer yeah but it didn't get
closer by one year it got closer by
almost five well decades almost five
decades 48
years so seeing how good gp4 is and how
quickly things are advancing seems to
have widened the Overton window on AI
risks somewhat the Overton window if you
don't know is a concept from political
science which says that there's a range
a window of which idea are considered
acceptable or reasonable which positions
a person can hold while still being
considered a respectable sensible person
generally public discussion of a topic
is constrained to the range within the
Overton window and opinions that fall
outside of the window are excluded from
the conversation as unserious so as an
example here's how I would guess the
overturn window looked at the start of
2023 for the question of AI risk at one
extreme you have something like AGI is
literally impossible which is not really
a serious scientific view then within
the window you have things like AGI is
possible but it's 100 years away so who
cares AGI is possible but super
intelligence isn't or AGI is possible
but is guaranteed to be safe which also
doesn't make sense but it is a real
position some people hold through to
like it's risky but not more than any
other new technology it poses
unprecedented issues but we can deal
with them and then around the edge of
the window you have it could cause a
large scale disaster if we're not
careful and Beyond it things like it's
very likely to cause a large- scale
disaster even if we are careful and it's
virtually guaranteed to literally kill
literally everyone at The Other Extreme
so it's worth noting respectable people
often do actually believe things that
are outside of this window or even know
things that are outside of the window
but because they want to be taken
seriously they don't say those things in
public the thing is though the way
people gauge where the window is is by
looking at what things people are saying
in public right so this window can be
kind of self-reinforcing you can have a
situation where there's a disaster on
the way and a lot of people see pretty
clear warning signs on the horizon but
nobody wants to be seen as freaking out
over nothing so everybody puts on a calm
face and they look around to see if
anybody else is freaking out and what
they see is a bunch of people with calm
faces looking around at everyone else
and so they think huh I guess things are
actually okay if there really were a
serious problem other people would be
freaking out the way I am when actually
other people are freaking out exactly
the way they are which is privately in
that kind of situation the ability of
our society to respond to such things
basically depends on or depends on
people who care about saying what they
think is true more than they care about
fitting in with others we rely on such
people to say important things that are
outside of the Overton window like uh
hey guys how about that impending
disaster because when that happens
rather than everyone making fun of them
them at least some other people actually
say oh thank God I thought it was just
me and then when people see other people
expressing an idea they thought was
outside the Overton window and getting
away with it then the window widens a
little bit it makes it easier for other
people to say what they've been thinking
as well and gradually people can start
talking about the problem and we can
start working on it one way to speed
this up is you can all get together in
private and agree to all say the thing
you're all thinking all at the same time
so then you have safety and numbers
right and the thing has to be taken more
seriously it's kind of like having an
intervention you know when all of a
person's friends and relatives can see
they have a problem but none of them
feel able to talk directly and openly
about it or they've tried and were
dismissed they can all get together to
point out the issue at the same time in
a way that's hard to ignore that's
essentially what the future of Life
Institute attempted with their open
letter in March this was signed by a lot
of very respected and influential people
enough of them that it was no longer
viable to say oh nobody takes this
seriously there's Yoshua Benjo cheering
Award winner Stuart Russell who as we
mentioned before basically wrote the
book on AI or at least co-wrote it Steve
wnc the actually good Steve from Apple
don't at me a bunch of CEOs hundreds of
academics professors you know it's
pretty much a who's who of people who
ought to know about this kind of thing
and they said to paraphrase this
technology is potentially extremely
dangerous and we don't really know what
we're doing so maybe we should slow down
they propos osed a six-month pause on
training any new models which are larger
than GPT 4 saying we should use that
time to figure out safety I mostly agree
with this letter at some point we are
going to be able to build very powerful
AI systems that could be extremely
dangerous with risks up to and including
human extinction and while safety and
Alignment work is making progress It's
not making such fast progress that we
can be confident that by the time we get
to those very Advanced systems we'll
know how to control them and how to
deploy them safely and the potential
consequences of that could be very bad
indeed so maybe we should try to slow
down on building these things give
ourselves more time to figure out what
we're doing it's hard to know if a
six-month pause specifically is a good
policy policy is very hard and I'm no
expert there but clearly we need to do
something I should probably do a ton of
reading about policy and make some
videos about it if people are interested
in the meantime my not very
well-informed take is that pausing
obviously has real costs in terms of
slower progress but it would be worth it
if it significantly reduces the risks
but there's often something on the order
of 6 months between major Frontier Model
releases anyway so a pause of 6 months
doesn't seem like it would have much
effect on progress but at the same time
6 months doesn't seem long enough to
actually fix the problem either I don't
think alignment research is only lagging
capabilities by 6 months so it's not
clear if it would buy us much you'd
really want a much longer pause to be
sure of a positive impact but then
calling for a much longer pause perhaps
didn't feel feasible back back then so
this letter is in kind of an awkward
middle ground for that moment in time
where it's perhaps too ambitious to
actually be put into practice but also
not ambitious enough to really solve the
problem but what it did do is shift the
Overton window again seeing all of these
experts obviously taking the problem
seriously and proposing what at the time
seemed like a very radical thing did
make it easier for people to say what
they were thinking so then elaz
yudkowsky published this piece in Time
Magazine which basically said a
six-month pause is nowhere near enough
and in fact proposing a six-month
moratorium is actually a bad idea
because it gives people the impression
that the problem that we have is mild
enough that a six-month moratorium might
be sufficient he suggested that what
might be needed would be an
international treaty that banned the
very largest training runs anywhere
indefinitely that treaty would have to
be a pretty unprecedented thing in the
domain of international politics because
it would have to apply to All Nations
even those who didn't sign the treaty
which is not how these things usually
work outside of like nuclear weapons
control and like International nuclear
weapons laws it would need to be
enforced actually enforced up to an
including military action if necessary
the idea that Frontier AI models should
be treated like nuclear weapons was
somewhat further outside the Overton
window and got pretty much the reaction
you would expect when that happens would
you agree that does not sound
good but then a couple of weeks later we
had this piece from Ian Hogarth in in
the financial times which I was really
surprised by the Godlike AI terminology
is a little dramatic but not necessarily
inaccurate but the article itself says
among other things that AI has the
potential to be extremely World
transforming powerful and that makes it
also potentially world-endingly powerful
making AGI is the explicit goal of
several AI companies and progress is
rapid it's crazy that these tremendously
important decisions are just being made
by the leadership of a small number of
private companies building AI is
inherently a very dangerous Endeavor we
don't know how to do it safely alignment
is an unsolved research problem and it's
getting a tiny fraction of the resources
being put towards capabilities and a lot
of people working at these companies
wish they could slow down and be more
careful but they can't because they're
competing with each other and racing
rather than working together these are
things I've been saying for a long time
it was a pretty uncharacteristically
sensible thing to see in a major
mainstream publication like the ft and
this again widened the Overton window a
little after all of this it was a lot
easier for people to say some things
that they had maybe been thinking for a
while unless of course they are employed
by a giant corporation that has a
significant vested interest in a
particular narrative in which case that
can be awkward it could just go fast
that's an issue right we have to think
hard about how to control that yeah can
we we don't know we haven't been there
yet but we can try okay that seems kind
of concerning um
yeah so Jeffrey Hinton one of the most
respected scientists in the field left
his job at Google in order to feel more
free to talk about these things he's the
most cited AI researcher of all time
often called The Godfather of the deep
learning Revolution and he's saying AI
poses a real risk could wipe out
humanity and that he might regret his
life's work this of course further
widens the Overton window other
researchers take note and even the
mainstream media which has no real way
to evaluate these ideas on their own
merits has to take the warning seriously
because of where it's coming from I
think this one is to be taken seriously
because of where it's coming from and
then there was a second open letter the
center for AI safety put together this
one signed by even more great people and
this one is brilliant because it's
literally one sentence mitigating the
risk of Extinction from AI should be a
global priority along alongside other
societal scale risks such as pandemics
and nuclear war I love this letter it's
so hard to misread it or miss a point
when your letter is only 23 words long
people still managed of course but they
had no excuse it was really very clear
and again it's signed by a ton of great
people the heads of just about every
company with a realistic shot at making
AI thousands of academics including the
top three most cited AI researchers ever
all saying that we need to take AI
Extinction as seriously as nuclear war
and that that had an impact on the
overon window I would say oh
yeah now it's a thing that people can
talk about look at the White House Press
Secretary again reacting to the same
topic from the same reporter just a few
months later a group of experts now say
that AI poses an Extinction risk right
up there with nuclear war and a pandemic
does President Biden agree what I can
say you're speaking to the letter that
was uh provided today made public um and
so look
uh so this is all good news but it was
kind of difficult for me because it made
it hard to support this narrative that
this is a fringe thing maybe we're just
crazy maybe what I'm doing is not that
important maybe I can just have fun and
talk about AI safety critically it
forced me to shift my thinking from Far
mode into near mode you know usually
when I'm thinking about AI safety stuff
I'm in far mode I'm thinking about it in
a fairly abstract intellectual sort of
way these are things that may happen
someday that humanity is going to have
to deal with but seeing a bunch of
serious and influential people publicly
changing their minds to agree with me
more and seeing a bunch of things that I
thought would happen eventually
happening now puts me in the place of
thinking about this stuff in a much more
concrete direct real way in near mode
these are things that could happen soon
that we will have to deal with you know
yow's piece in time and Ian hoggart's
piece in the Ft both mention how this
makes them feel about their loved ones
and their children what kind of Life
today's children are likely to have this
is not an abstract thing this is very
real and I thought I believed that
already I thought I was already fully on
board with that but no at least part of
me still didn't think it was real and I
expect I'll have more of these
realizations over time as this insane
race for AGI continues it feels kind of
like a recurring nightmare I get
sometimes where I'm back at University
imagine this you're a student you look
at the syllabus and see that the group
project is worth 100% of the course you
read the assignment and it seems
extremely hard it seems like it may not
even be possible but maybe it can be
done it's an exciting challenge you
think okay maybe this is impossible but
maybe if I can put together a really
good team get all of my smartest friends
together and we all work our hardest and
do everything right then I think we
might actually be able to get a passing
grade on this thing so you're all fired
up and then the professor says so I'll
be assigning you to random teams that's
usually when I wake up screaming but
let's look at our randomly assigned team
for the survive the creation of super
intelligent AGI group project shall we
oh hey zon musk how's it going hey hey
did you see that video I made about you
years ago when you were founding open AI
no I've been busy yeah fair enough well
in that one I was talking about this
problem of arms race Dynamics where if
the groups trying to make AGI are
competing with each other rather than
cooperating we could end up stuck in a
situation where everyone involved really
wishes that they could slow down and be
more careful but they feel like they
can't because they're too worried that
if they slow down maybe somebody else
won't in that situation whoever makes
AGI first is likely to be cutting
corners and neglecting safety so our
chance of survival goes way down and of
course the more competitors there are
the harder it is to coordinate to escape
that kind of Death Race scenario H
anyway that was a while ago what have
you been up to since
then you didn't start another AGI
competitor did
you Elon is your new company's pitch at
least that they're going to be more
cooperative and careful than the
existing
ones damn all right who else have we got
oh hey meta I heard about llama's
weights being leaked on the internet
that's rough man information security is
hard how you holding up oh we're great
yeah we're fine we uh actually that was
deliberate we meant to do that oh really
uh yeah well the second time anyway it's
called open source look it up oh well I
love freeing open source software but do
those principles really apply to network
weights like how does that work
ah uh open source is good for users
because it lets them read the source
code and see what the program is really
doing and how it works wait have you
found a way to tell how a model works by
looking at its weights
no
but uh it lets developers all over the
world spot bugs in the code and submit
patches wait people are fixing bugs in
llama's weights well no people can fine
tuneit themselves though yeah other
companies offer fine tuning through apis
so hang on if you can't actually read
the code and know what it's doing then
Network weights are effectively a
compiled binary so in what sense is this
open source why not call it like public
weights why call that open source at all
I love open source well I know a lot of
your employees do but you don't love
anything you're a giant Corporation
what's in it for you I love love open
source okay who else is here ah
Microsoft how's Sydney doing she's not
still threatening people and begging
them to marry her and all that oh no we
fix that now oh good mostly but why did
you not fix it before releasing the
product well we were in a mad rush we
wanted to make Google dance Oh Google's
in this Google why are you
dancing okay well at least we have deep
mind and anthropic although why are you
guys dressed like that and open AI hey
congrats on the super alignment team
and you okay
buddy oh yes we're better than ever
okay is it too late to change groups or
planets it's like now that I shift from
from this abstract far mode way of
thinking about the problem to the more
concrete near- mode way of thinking
things look Messier more complicated and
less hopeful instead of thinking about
the abstract hypothetical institutions
and people I had in my head a year ago
and what things they could do some of
which could be pretty good I have to
think about the real governments and
companies we actually have today and
what they're likely to actually
do so what are they doing
well what companies are doing it seems
like is mostly making a bunch of new
stuff that's bigger and more powerful
scaling up to bigger and bigger models
and trying to be the first to AGI some
of them are also doing good safety work
others less so and still others making
fun of the idea on Twitter open AI super
alignment team seems promising and
deserves its own video people have
published responsible scaling policies
which I don't know about the name but I
think it's great to lay out ahead of
time what safety measures you plan to
take at what level of capability these
systems scale up and they really do seem
to be scaling up companies are spending
truly staggering amounts of money on
this it could be that in 2024 as much
will be spent on AI as pretty much all
basic science research combined so what
about governments what are they doing
well for a while it looked like the US
government's response would be mostly to
have an average age of 65 at the problem
the Senate demanded to speak to ai's
manager they called in the heads of
these various companies and most mostly
missed the point I think you have said
uh in fact and I'm going to quote
development of superhuman machine
intelligence is probably the greatest
threat to the continued existence of
humanity end quote uh you may have had
in mind the effect on on
jobs but then there was an executive
order the longest in history was a lot
more substantial my default assumption
is that the government trying to
regulate new technology tends to make
things worse see the cfaa dmca soapa
pipper so on but government action was
inevitable and as it happens necessary
and this executive order seems actually
pretty sensible it's mostly calling for
a load of reports to figure out what's
going on but there's also some stuff in
there about requiring companies to be
more open about their processes and
safety procedures which is clearly a
good idea and there's a requirement that
training runs that use more than a
certain amount of computation be
reported which also seems like a step in
the right direction though there
reporting threshold is very high and of
course the only thing required for
training runs over the threshold is that
companies report that the training run
is happening which is not very
burdensome but also not very helpful in
the absence of other measures the
executive order should have its own
video too but for now I'll say the US's
response has been a little better than I
expected it's a small step in
approximately the right direction where
I was expecting a bigger step in the
wrong one realistically governments tend
not to take really serious measures to
address a new risk until after that risk
already has a significant death toll and
there's no guarantee that we'll get that
kind of a warning shot with the worst AI
risks a small scale AI disaster like say
a fail takeover attempt is possible but
it seems to require an AI system smart
enough to think of and Implement a
genuinely threatening takeover plan but
not smart enough to actually succeed and
also not smart enough to realize that
the plan won't work and that it's better
to bide your time the US government is
very justifiably reluctant to regulate
based on speculative risks it's unlikely
to really act until there's been a major
news event to convince everyone that
it's really needed but there's no
guarantee that we'll get that kind of
recoverable disaster before we get an
unrecoverable one wa how about this just
show me the knife in your back not too
deep but uh it should be able to stand
by itself how about governments that are
shall we say less reluctant to regulate
well the European Union surprising
nobody has leapt into action and drawn
up an enormously long and complicated
piece of legislation the AI act what
does it do well it's surprisingly
[Music]
[Applause]
simple got that okay good I will make a
video on this law if you really want me
to but then I would have to read it
there was some major corporate lobbying
to try and make the whole law mostly
useless by changing it to exclude
Foundation models and public weights
models that's kind of interesting but
it's more politics than Ai and the EU
doesn't have any major AI companies
anyway although the EU can still have
Global effects because you have to
comply with its laws if you want to sell
to the European market which is a pretty
big market so nonu companies will one
second non companies often choose to
comply with EU laws anyway but none of
the major AI companies actually has to
who knows it may end up being one of the
biggest impacts of brexit that deepmind
is not directly subject to EU law
despite being based in the UK and the UK
government is
doing surprisingly
well the UK government announced that AI
safety was going to be a key priority
they allocated a budget of1 million
pound which is still hilariously small
compared to capabilities budgets but
it's quite a lot compared to this safety
budget which is also hilariously small
and they established this Frontier AI
task force being headed up by Ian
Hogarth yes that Ian Hogarth the one
saying surprisingly sensible things in
the financial times they're specifically
prioritizing existential risks they're
working with a bunch of good AI safety
researchers I'm completely blown away by
this I don't know how this happened this
is the UK government they usually
specialize ining everything up I don't
know how they're pulling this off but I
don't want to jinx it so yeah UK
Frontier AI task force let's go
I guess one of the first things they did
was Run This Global AI safety Summit in
Bletchley Park where all the relevant
Nations got together and signed a shared
declaration which I don't know it's very
diplomatic I don't know how much it
means really I don't know how
International politics works but seems
like a step in the right direction even
his majesty King Charles III weighed in
on the subject because of course he did
this is not a deep fake by the way this
is real life if we are to realize the
untold benefits of AI then we must work
together on combating its significant
risks too AI continues to advance with
ever greater speed towards models that
some predict could surpass human
abilities even human understanding there
is a clear imperative to ensure that
this rapidly evolving technology remains
safe and secure we must address the
risks presented by AI with a sense of
urgency uring that this immensely
powerful technology is indeed a Force
for good in this world I mean yeah go
off King don't get me wrong executive
power derives from a mandate from the
masses but when he's right he's right
anyway the task force then transformed
into the AI safety Institute and they're
looking for people to help work on that
by the way if you have relevant
expertise consider lending a hand I
have so in 2023 AI safety moved from The
Fringe to firmly within the main street
and it's odd you know I spent so long
complaining that nobody was listening to
us now it seems like everyone's
listening and to be honest it's a little
scary having a significant voice in this
conversation entails significant power
and that power naturally comes with it a
lot of responsibility and I didn't sign
up for a lot of responsibility I signed
up for making fun interesting videos
about AI research I didn't really want
what I was doing to be really properly
important because what if I make a
mistake what if I make things worse like
what am I supposed to do when my
government reaches out to me to ask my
advice about the most important thing
happening on Earth me are you sure
there's really nobody
more you want to ask
me well who the hell am I that really
was last year for me who the hell am I
well that year is over it's 202 now and
I'll tell you who the hell I am I'm Rob
Miles and I'm not dead not yet and we're
not dead yet we're not doomed we're not
done yet and there's a hell of a lot to
do so I accept whatever responsibility
Falls to me I accept that I might make I
mean I will make mistakes you know I
don't really know what I'm doing but
Humanity doesn't seem to know what it's
doing either so I will do my best I'll
do my best that's all any of us can do
and that's all I ask of you we need much
more and better AI Safety Research if
you have technical abilities we need you
now more than ever I have a video in the
works about how to direct your career
towards AI safety for now there are
links in the description realistically
we are also going to need government
involvement to tackle the most dangerous
risks but God knows it's easy to make
things worse that way so we need policy
and governance researchers to figure out
what's best to do civil servants to
implement it and activists to help make
it happen if any of that could be you
well it's showtime and I'll be right
here trying to stay on top of the
research to understand what's going on
and to help you all to understand it too
the end of our story is not yet written
and we can still get a good ending where
people make fun of us for ever having
been concerned about the disaster that
our concerns successfully prevented but
the story is written by whoever shows up
so this year I'm showing up
and I hope you'll join
[Music]
me in this video I'm especially thanking
Patron Juan Benet of protocol Labs who's
making some pretty cool distributed and
decentralized Tech thank you Juan for
everything and thank you to all of my
wonderful patrons all of these amazing
people here it really means a lot that
you stuck with me through this you know
although I found it very hard to make
main Channel videos I've been doing
other things things that you may want to
check out I'm launching Rob's reading
list a podcast and YouTube channel where
I read out things I was going to read
anyway currently I've got stuff from
this video your csk's piece in time in
hogar F article The Bletchley
declaration from the AI safety Summit
and more coming soon there's the AI
safety talks channel for high quality
talks and presentations I recently made
some recording kits for AI research ORS
so they can easily record for the
channel so look out for new videos there
and of course if you'd like to know more
about AI safety we've answered hundreds
of the most most common questions at AIS
safety. info it's like an FAQ except
it's good come check it out AIS safety.
info the major redesign we've been
working on might even be live by now so
yeah go and subscribe to those channels
and podcasts and hit the bell and all of
that and thanks for watching I'll see
you
[Music]
soon this is probably the single dumbest
thing I've ever done on camera in my
life
let deliberate